[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
hello there tonight on Piers Morgan
uncensored with me Rosanna Lockwood
Britain is said to remain on cause for
the worst economic performance of any
country in the G7 this year but what is
to blame for our unstable and fragile
economy is it Global turmoil or is it
brexit as the latest AI generators
broadcaster makes her debut in Q8
leaving mere mortal news readers
questioning their future will be
debating whether the race to develop
artificial intelligence systems is out
of control
and after an animal rights groups
confirmed their plans to disrupt the
Grand National this weekend will be
taking a closer look at horse Racing's
Flagship event there's calls for a
boycott grow
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Rosanna Lockwood
now I know I know we're sick of talking
about it we had a vote the people
decided that's democracy let's get
brexit done and move on but the point is
every month with more data we get more
concrete evidence that brexit has had
and is going to continue to have a
material negative impact on our economy
the UK I'm afraid to say it's not
prospering at the moment we are forecast
to be the worst performing large
Advanced economy this year our Goods
exports are the lowest and the G7 GDP
figures out today for February show our
growth flatlining and British living
standards are forecast for the biggest
two-year decline ever recorded now I
don't need to tell you all this because
you can see it can't you you're
experiencing every day when you go to
the supermarket when you're at home when
you look at your savings saying all of
this that it doesn't make me unpatriotic
to point it out it doesn't mean I hate
the UK in fact it's my love for the UK
that makes me so passionate about this
topic I'm really proud of this country
that's why I don't like seeing us so
bottom of the pack and none of this is
about questioning the 2016 Vote or
asking for another one God forbid
I don't personally care how you voted
back then but I do care how we deal with
this now and how we deal with each other
in fact let's stop using these Ramona
these brexiteer titles shall we all they
do is pit us against each other
we're stronger together and when we look
at the facts in front of us and demand
honesty and demand better performance
from the people who led us into this
situation joining us in the talk TV
studios presenter and staunch breakfast
here I think it's fair to say Richard
Tice just going to give you the
opportunity to respond absolutely
Rosanna I can't believe you've fallen
for it you've asked for honesty but
you've fallen for the Ramon language
look it's quite clear what's causing the
flatlining at the moment even the IMF
that have produced the forecast in the
last few days the IMF who were against
brexits who would look for any
opportunity to say that it was all
brexit's faults for our flatlining they
didn't use the word once why because
it's got nothing to do with it Rosanna
I'm delighted to have this opportunity
to explore this what actually it's all
about is first of all the huge number of
strikes we've got which is recognized
our rate of inflation is one of the
worst in the G20 then of course we've
got the very high Gas and energy prices
All Because Of The Madness of Net Zero
that's causing a massive problem for
consumers and for businesses uh so we've
got the strikes and then also taxes and
regulations one of the great
opportunities for brexit that the con
socialist stories have failed to take
advantage of is the ability to cut taxes
hard and to go for growth cut
unnecessary dafty your regulations they
haven't bothered wearing any of that and
here's a point which lots of people on
The Remains I'd say is to blame is the
labor shortages but actually we haven't
got a labor shortage yes we do we don't
have a labor shortage we've got the
highest population ever I've just come
back from France they've also got labor
shortages they're still in the European
Union as you well know it's got nothing
to do with we've got 5.2 million people
of our own on out of work benefits we've
got a willing worker problem because
their taxes are too high so work is not
paying in this country for too many
people on Modest or low incomes the
reality is that work doesn't pay
relative to for example being on
benefits and working let's say 16 hours
a week these are the sort of issues that
are causing our economy you didn't
mention in your intro that also Germany
is
forecasting I thought and Germany again
is still in the European Union why are
they struggling for the same reasons to
do with energy because they also have
adopted The Madness of Net Zero which
means that instead of using nuclear
fuels which they've done
um in the past they've got rid of all
that they've gone down the renewable
thing and then they got exposed to
Russia and that's had a huge impact on
uh on their economy and their growth so
look the reality is these numbers have
that they're all flatlining they're all
terrible we agreed on that you said
let's move forward with honesty and and
you can't grow an economy if you tax our
way out of existence with high
regulations that surely is what we've
got to agree we've got to cut taxes go
for growth cut up wasteful unnecessary
government spending and then we will be
much more prosperous as a nation Richard
I can't believe you said you couldn't
believe I'd fallen for it the Ramona
language when I couldn't believe the way
that the country was led into this
decision by certain people who were
voting for brexit at the time and you
know the points that you've laid out yes
there is a labor shortage we have got
record unemployment record employment in
the UK rather but we have got a huge
amount of vacancies that unfill speak to
anybody anecdotally in the business
Market they will tell you there is a
massive labor problem and they don't
tell you that one and eight of our
working age population is now to work
benefits we've got a willing worker
shortage not people shortage and when it
comes to other countries when we look at
Global issues things like covid the
pandemic the energy crisis inflation
those are Global issues they've been
caused by a myriad of economic factors
that have affected countries around the
world we had one of the highest most
wasteful spending of government money
through the whole lockdown process
because of our lockdown policies it
wasn't covered it was our response to it
fundamentally flawed our response was
not unique the the British response in
lockdown was replicated and stronger in
many other countries we were the only
country to unilaterally Place trading
barriers on our closest trading partner
that is what sets us out as different
the German example I want to highlight
because Italy France and Spain
absolutely bouncing into recovery
Eurozone very very healthy too the
government is generous on their lockdown
policies that's the reality look at
Sweden for example which looks a
completely different view of lockdowns
they didn't suffer the huge extra cost
expense and now their economy is doing
much better so there are multiple
reasons but I do come back to the
fundamental point if anybody was going
to use brexit as an excuse it would be
the IMF and they didn't because it's not
true and I'm being honest with you I
look I want to bring up anecdotal things
here because you speak to people in the
UK and I I think this is really
important to listen to businesses to
listen to people and what they're saying
this letter was sent into the Financial
Times by The managing director of a lace
company in Derbyshire they make they
send it to France to be died and then
they get it back he said in their case
with these post-brexit trade rules hmrc
are levying and eight percent duty
backdated to brexit he finishes by
saying they have spent more than 200
years building their business in
Derbyshire they fought for 30 years
against the global textile trend of
moving to the Far East and they have now
been quote killed off by our own side in
a couple of years we all those hmrcs and
this governments this Tory government's
utter stupidity we don't need to do that
the whole point of doing brexit was so
that we can make our own decisions this
Tory government they got brexit over the
line but they haven't taken advantage
that's their fault it's not the fault of
those of us the recommended brexit are
being the right thing to do it's still a
great platform of opportunity and we
should unify and go for it put the
shoulder behind the wheel put the foot
flat on the accelerator of growth and
success but you can't do that if you've
got an hmrc and a Tory government that
refuses to do it look I there was a poll
recently a statistic poll that asked
britons if they would still vote for
brexit 55 this was a poll taken last
month uh said that they think it was the
wrong idea to leave the EU of course
that's a different uh you know a size of
people let's go to the poll result that
was taken in the polls just before the
brexit vote all the polls then said that
remain would win and all the polls were
were wrong because they didn't
understand the gut instinct of the Great
British people and the people voted for
it but what people did quite reasonably
expect is that the government of under
Boris Johnson would then take advantage
of the opportunities that they espoused
and that's what they've utterly failed
to do so it's a failure of this story
government rather than the failure of
the fundamental Concept in the first
place isn't that a bit convenient for
you to say given that you were such a
staunch box of tear back in 2016 and you
still are clearly but that you say it's
an implementation issue with the current
government isn't that because I'm not in
the current government because I lead a
different party that obviously was the
brexit party we know how to make a huge
success of it and we are still
absolutely banging the calls that it's
the right thing to do because it is but
like anything in life if you're going to
do a job do it properly or don't do it
at all don't do a half job and that's
what the Tories have done they've sort
of limped out they've left the Northern
Ireland handcuffed into the EU and then
they haven't taken advantage of the
opportunities that they said they
haven't even cut levees and VAT on
energy bills which we could do they
haven't cut v80 on energy
um uh and on consumer goods which would
reduce inflation all these things they
could do they haven't knowing what you
do now because hindsight's a glorious
thing isn't it it's 2020 would you have
campaigned for brexit in exactly the
same way that you did back in 2016
knowing what you do now knowing the data
we've got out would you do it the same
way even harder really with with more
Spirit but what I would have done
absolutely what you've got to do in any
negotiation you've got to be prepared to
walk away because Theresa May's
government wasn't that was why the
negotiations went wrong so we didn't get
the right sort of deal and we limped
over Richard we bought you one because
we knew the position you were going to
take you haven't surprised me one bit I
do hope you'll join us at the end of the
show to talk through a few more stories
of the day in the in the Regular Pack
but now I want to get the views of an
economist on this issue Professor Danny
blanch flower form of it Banker Bank of
England policy rather advisor joins me
live Danny thanks so much for making
time for us hope you listen to that
debate just now with Richard just get
your immediate response
well we had Gremlins so I only heard a
little bit of it
um I mean I think it's kind of you know
the the ship has sunk and
um no regrets I mean the reality is that
brexit is an economist
brexit was always going to be an
economic disaster
um and it's turned out to be that way
and I've long said to people please
would you tell me an economic benefit
yet of brexit and to this point nobody's
actually ever come up with one and I
think the reality has to sort of hit you
know the reality has to hit the road
right here I mean yesterday we got a
report from the IMF giving a forecast
for all the advanced and less developed
countries guess who's worst in the UK
why well brexit so it's rare and Dan I
think it's red so isn't it that uh
economists reach consensus on some
issues there seems to be a consensus
that there's a growth issue in the UK
but how much consensus is there among
economists that brexit is to blame for
the UK's growth problem well I mean I
think it's interesting I mean how many
matelets talked about this some time ago
I mean at the time of when the debate
was on about brexit there were thousands
and thousands of economists who
basically said the same thing as I've
just said and I think there were
probably fives who got onto every TV
program
um essentially saying if you like just
equivalent that the world was flat
um and so basically the consensus before
it happened was the same the consensus
now is the same and the only issue is
how disastrous is it I mean the question
you have to ask for anybody who thinks
brexit was a great idea what's the
explanation of why the UK is is
basically the the sick man of Europe the
sick man of the oecd
um and what explains that there's a
simple explanation nation which is
Investments falling in the UK mobile
workers that were here are greasing the
wheels of the labor market have left
um and essentially we saw data today
saying the export performance of the UK
was completely disastrous and also worst
of the in the in in the Western World so
I don't really know what anyone's argued
about I mean you can you could do the
canoe the king Canute thing saying you
know hold back the tide but I mean the
jury the jury came back the fat lady
started singing there is no debate
anymore it's an unmitigated disaster and
you can't eat sovereignty I mean that's
as simple as it is uh Danny I want to
ask you one point that Richard brought
up when I was debating just now he said
the UK doesn't have a labor issue I
think it does
well sure it does I mean the big the big
issue it has is that people can't afford
to pay their bills even if they're
working and why are so many people on
strike public sector pay is so low
people are struggling to survive their
real wages have fallen
um but they're so there clearly is a
labor issue and one of the big reasons
people have retired actually is the jobs
that are not paying enough real pay in
many jobs has actually fallen and people
the older people have decided the
benefit of going to work is less than
the benefit of not going to work so so
um the answer is of course there's a an
economic problem
um basically it's about paying your
bills and and obviously we also had a
disastrous government trying to trot out
right-wing stuff that the brexit is
supported and the Prime Minister lasted
48 days and I I actually wrote I think
in July 2022 saying that this isn't
always going to be a disaster the bond
market is the foreign exchange James
Marcus would come after you and boy did
they so this is just all a set of
economic policies that are a disaster
Danny just to end on a positive note if
we can because I want to avoid you and I
being labeled as ramonas in all those uh
because we're realists weren't realist
exactly one of Richard's key points
though is it's an implementation issue
of the current government so if that is
the argument to take how much longer do
we give them
we don't give them any much longer we
know the answer
what's the solution is
well we have to try and work out ways of
making the connections to our close
neighbors much greater we have to deal
with the with the issue of pay we have
to deal with the issue of goods and
people moving across Frontiers again and
basically do everything you can to
reverse everything that the brexiteers
did I mean everything you think every
policy they did let's just reverse it
allow start to allow free movement of
peoples allow Goods to cross Frontiers
and not have to bother with ridiculous
trade deals with some East Asian
Southeast Asian country that will raise
GDP by 0.0001 in a decade and that was
considered to be an overestimate as well
yeah I know I know
the zeros have it look Daddy thank you
very much for adding to this debate and
thank you Richard in the studio as well
now we do have more coming up on the
show are we all at risk of losing our
jobs to AI if it's not anything else
critics say AI will lead to mass
unemployment whilst others say it will
move Humanity forward we're talking
about that next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
fabulous
but Rishi suno sets out this five-point
plan what has it achieved so far enough
when we say believe women take them at
their word I'm sick of apology
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
very beloved let us bright they're
careful who are we praying to exactly
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
now artificial intelligence is it our
new best friend or worst enemy in Kuwait
AI Bots have started reading the news
which means journalists could be out of
a job including you Rosanna
I don't think so
I really really is that what's going to
replace US News readers and presenters
I'd like to see their moderate of brexit
debate but of course this is a more
serious topic that was an AI bot
speaking the words written by our
producer Kieran very smart bear Kieran
but it does raise this important
question is AI a threat to the jobs of
almost all of us everyone from doctors
to teachers could see themselves made
redundant by new technology that's
faster and more intelligent than the
average human
but will all of it result in this
dystopian future where we'll be slaves
to AI overlords or a more utopian World
freeing us from the shackles of nine to
five living free to pursue more
leisurely activities here to discuss all
of this AI skeptic and director of the
future of humanity Institute at Oxford
University Professor Nick Bostrom Nick
thank you ever so much for making time
to speak to us and you know I know we
can oversimplify this and talk about
sort of robots taking our jobs it seems
to be that's what the media most grasps
onto but give us a sense of the power of
AI if you could
well I think we are just at the early
stages of what might become the biggest
transition in human history the arrival
of the machine intelligence era
um long ago we have sort of automated a
lot of human physical labor
um first through draft animals and then
with steam engines and so forth and now
we're starting to automate human
cognitive labor
how dangerous is that to replicate
cognitive behavior
well I've long argued that this
development of machine general
intelligence and as I think shortly
thereafter machine super intelligence
will be associated with significant
existential risks like threats to the
very survival of the human species
um all so however I think if we get it
right uh it presents tremendous
opportunities to to solve you know a
very wide range of different problems
that have plagued Humanity uh throughout
our history you have argued that
sentient machines are a greater threat
than climate change at some point do you
stick by that
yeah that's that's my assessment
um
I think
um both in terms of time scale
um there's a lot of uncertainty about
that but in the last several years
progress in AI has been
really quite impressive
um and also about the risks if and when
we do reach human equivalence and then
Super intelligence
it's just something completely
unprecedented we've never developed
super intelligences before and uh I
think we might only get one try on this
we need we need to get it right on the
first shot
um because once you have
unfriendly antagonistic
superintelligence it might not be
possible to sort of put that Genie back
into the bottle
um so we've got to get it right for at
the first try and it looks quite
challenging to do that just to make sure
that it's aligned and does what we
actually want to do I mean it does sound
terrifying this idea of super
intelligence I've seen it described as
god-like super intelligence and I
remember having beers with a friend a
few years ago and he was saying the
thing I'm most scared about super
computers and I thought he was off his
rocket this was probably about seven
years ago he was right back then how how
far along the curve are we and how fast
is the train going in terms of being
able to Reign it in if we need to
the trade is going really fast I mean
everybody have seen these recent
um large language models with chatipit
for it seems like almost every other day
there is like a big new release
um the image generation models like
everything you see in this picture is
artificial right the virtual backdrop
actually generated by one of these uh
Dali 2 image generation models I'm not
even sure whether I'm real or artificial
um and it looks like
this current algorithms
generalize very well and scale so you
pour in more compute you pour in more
data and and they just seem to reach
higher levels of performance with as yet
no player end in sight
um there was an open letter being spread
around the technology in the AI
Community Elon Musk was one of the
signatories saying we need to pause the
development of AI uh in order to assess
some of these risks you can see that we
can call on all AI uh developers to stop
this immediately pause for at least six
months he's asking for the training of
AI systems more powerful than gpt4 I
believe that Bill Gates was actually not
one of the signatories of those and he
has made the case that we do need to
keep the development of AI up in the
west because otherwise we're going to
fall out of the race when it comes to
competing with China and obviously there
could be risks involved with that
yeah right now the the Western
particularly certain large Western tech
companies I think have a lead uh
things are quite competitive in this
space
um also in terms of building the
computer hardware
that is needed to run these large AI
models they keep producers of that are
in the United States in Taiwan and in
South Korea
um and recent export regulations have
tried to style me the sales of AI chips
into China so that might make it harder
for Chinese developers to to keep up
with The Cutting Edge I think ultimately
machine super intelligence should be
developed I I do think during the key
parts of the transition though it would
be wise to be able to do it carefully
and not to have a sort of hyper
competitive situation where there are 20
different companies that are each viring
to get their first and the whoever
decides to make some extra precautions
or to check their systems like carefully
just immediately falls behind and the
race is won by whoever is willing to
take most risks I think that would be a
bad situation so having some ability to
coordinate uh maybe to slow down for a
few months I think that could be a
positive yeah ideally you'd want it to
happen in concert but of course in the
real world companies compete in
countries compete and this idea of
having one of the most consequential
technological impacts on Earth as you as
you sort of laid out at the beginning of
our conversation just how severe it
could be and all these decisions being
made by a small handful of tech
companies private companies don't
regular people deserve a say in this
yeah I think the development of of
machine superintelligence is really an
issue not just for one company or even
one country it's an issue for for all of
humanity we we are all in this boat
together like if it goes badly we're all
doomed and if it goes well I think we
should all uh you know have a slice uh
of The Upside as well and so I think
this conversation will need to and I
think it will broaden out policy makers
are getting a lot more interested I
think people as they start to get
first-hand experience using these
systems and seeing how they get better
so quickly I think that that will focus
a lot of attention on this over the
coming months and uh years I I I think
you're right in saying that everyone's
sort of experimenting now a lot of
people know what chat GPT is they're
starting to see the power of this
hopefully we'll find a way for us not
all to be doomed Nick Bostrom director
the future of humanity Institute thanks
so much for joining us this evening
thank you well still to come here on the
show one of the biggest events in the
sporting calendar that is the grand
national a dangerous and morally dubious
fixture or simply a brilliant spectacle
we should all get behind we'll be
discussing next
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage stretching it you
can say whatever gender you are for your
sex your male or your female all right
JJ plus he becomes fabulous
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
okay
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
very beloved that's a surprise
too exactly it's just like some kind of
Submarine prime minister you're making
the case here now a MILF stands for
mother I'd like to I'm not going to say
the next word pop the kettle on this is
the royalty
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
[Music]
this is talk TV
thank you
welcome back to the Show Off to the
Races the Grand National one of the most
famous horse races watched by millions
around the world and it's taking place
this coming Saturday it's also one of
the most controversial sporting events
of the year campaigners have spent years
calling for a boycott arguing the race
is too dangerous for both horses and
jockeys and therefore morally dubious
already and tragically a horse named
Envoy special has died on the first tree
of Entry first day rather of Aintree
following a fatal force that puts this
uh gives us a bit of backdrop for this
discussion joining me now in the studio
Alex Lockwood a spokesperson for animal
Rising who plans to protest well the
organization does at the Grand National
and Kevin Blake a horse racing
journalist who joins us live from
Tipperary thank you gentlemen both I'll
come to Alex first and I should point
out that despite us sharing the same
surname Alex Lockwood and I do not have
any relations in common we've just
sussed that out so there's no bias in
this debate but I also wanted to
disclose that I probably do have a bit
of bias in this debate because I'm a
very keen horse rider
um so let's get on to talking about this
and uh give us a sense Alex of what
you're seeking to achieve by maybe
staging this protester entry sure thank
you and thank first of all thanks for
having us on so I I think in the UK we
can be rightly proud of ourselves as
being a nation of animal lovers
um and uh that the behavior towards
animals though sometimes fall short of
those values and that's particularly in
the food system of course but also in
events like the Grand National as you
said Envoy special has already died at
this year's grand national meeting we
think that's harmful we think it's wrong
we think the majority of the British
public support our views and feel the
same and we'd really like to call on
people to come down and support us and
sort of disrupt in the race because what
we want to do is shine a spotlight on
the treatment of animals in this country
and and show that we've actually got a
broken relationship with animals and the
natural world and that's at the center
of a lot of our problems such as the
climate crisis all right I want to go
into some of those points in more detail
but first want to get to Kevin and get
his response to that and hear a little
bit about your knowledge and expertise
in this and obviously you're probably
quite used to coming up against this
type of debate
hi Rosanna yeah Percy thank you very
much for the opportunity to come on it's
much appreciated
um and very happy to talk about this
race horse racing in general
um look it's it's interesting that Alex
feels that the majority of the British
public would be on his side of this
argument
um as far as I'm aware they're expecting
maybe 100 or 200 protesters Alex can
correct me if I'm if I'm off the mark
there but five to six hundred million
people all around the world will take
time out of their day to watch this race
on Saturday you know the race is not
perfect
um and it isn't without risk no one
would ever claim that but the fact that
five to six hundred million people are
going to tune in to watch it live I feel
is an extremely strong vote of
confidence from the court of public
opinion does
million people are tuning in to watch
this and it has so much support
um give Alex some ammunition to raise
issues about animal awareness isn't it
something that we should keep in the
conversation about the race if so many
people are watching
absolutely Rosanna look racing itself is
on this and has been on it for decades
look it's very important for those that
don't watch horse racing every day to
know that the Grand National is a very
different race this coming Saturday than
what it was in relatively recent times
like if you go on YouTube and watch Red
Rome winning the Grand National in the
1970s like what you see is a completely
different spectacle to what we see on
Saturday you know defenses have been
massively modified everything around the
race has been modified with a view to
reducing avoidable risk and they've had
very good results in looking to achieve
that and the most recent changes were
made to defenses after the 2012 renewal
and since then like the race has has
never been safer the fatality rate has
dropped to 1.1 percent it's never been
lower than that the average number of
fallers in those nine renewals has
dropped to five compared to 11.6 in the
previous renewals prior to those changes
so so nobody made horse racing make
these changes Rosanna this was all
self-driven in the best interest of
reducing avoidable risk the problem that
we have and we have in life is that risk
can never be eliminated it's about us as
intelligent reasonable people deciding
what qualifies as acceptable risk we do
this in our lives every single day and
across the board in British horse racing
the fatality rate has reduced to
0.2 percent of all runners okay trust me
when I say that there's there's a whole
bunch of people that are working to keep
that coming down but it's reduced by one
third in the last 20 years Rosanna and
it's very important to emphasize that
but we are on this and we care more than
anyone about reducing that number as low
as we possibly can I'm hearing some very
very clear action that has been taken
there's some very clear statistics I
want to put it to to Alex here in the
studio you can hear compromises being
made not in compromises actual care for
animal welfare and safety people in the
horse race industry many do really care
for the welfare of horses don't you
agree with that I do agree with that but
what Kevin said there is that no one
cares more but actually we do because we
don't want any fatalities on the course
and look a horse dies every other day in
British horse racing and that's just on
the tracks back in the Stables back in
the paddocks more die uh two thousand of
the whole you know 2 000 horses end up
in slaughterhouses like 50 of those have
racing passports you know this is what
happens to those horses who can't run
fast enough so for example the jockey
who was The Whistleblower who who told
about the um that the shooting of Young
Horses Falls 18 of them who couldn't run
fast enough to make a profit for the
industry what we're about and what we're
trying to shine a light on is that
people making profit off of animals is
wrong and that's in the food system in
horse racing anywhere you know we're
we're in 2023 you know like we've got
rid of dog fighting you know we're
trying to get rid of you know Fox you
know fox hunting you know like horses
cruel and and further for the animals
you know and it's as much as Kevin would
like to think you know all of these
jockeys all of these things really care
actually if there's no money involved
they wouldn't care Kevin
it was I kind of can't believe that that
Alex has just mentioned dog fighting and
tried to compare that to horse racing
like come on what are we doing here
um like in terms of
um it all being about profit like again
it shows a lack of understanding of
horse racing because the racehorse
ownership in itself like is a huge loss
making Endeavor like across the industry
okay in British horse racing a racehorse
owner can expect to get back on average
about 20 of the money they invest in
they don't do it to make money they do
it because they love the sport they love
the horses they love the experiences
they're being involved in the sport can
give them if they go in thinking they're
going to make a profit they're foolish
because it's just not the case in the
vast majority of cases this isn't about
a profit making exercise it's the love
of a sport and like in terms of you want
to talk about care you know I'd be
interested to hear if Alex has ever been
in a racing yard on a soap farm and
seeing the level of care of these
animals guess like this like there is no
animal on the planet that gets a higher
level of care every day from the very
beginning
after they retired Alex have you been on
a stud Farm have you been to one of
these racing facilities I've been to
racing facilities I've been on farms as
well sort of like dairy farm sheep farms
I've interviewed a lot of these people
Racing Stables have you been in Alex as
a matter of Interest I'd be familiar
with most trainers in the UK yeah those
are those around Newcastle where we live
um what I'd like to get to well I'd like
to get to the point of view you can't
name you can't name one though for
example so it might might I understand
the attention I understand the
attraction and the attachment that
people have to also my mum actually had
you know she worked in a betting shop
when I was growing up She had she had a
70th share in a horse like you know she
she went to
um Epsom Derby for her Hindu when she
got remarried I understand the the
attachment that people have to horse
racing but what we're saying is that no
horse should die you know we're we're a
nation of animal lovers we're really
proud
sorry Alex Kevin Kevin chance me out
there that every horse dies but there's
there's death of an actual life isn't
there and then there is I mean let's
talk about let's talk about it we all
die Rosanna every animal dies but not
every animal lives with the quality of
life that a racehorse gets like okay I
own a soda Farm here like we we have
brood mares we breed thoroughbreds you
know I have a bunch of horses outside
from one day old up to a 22 year old
retired mayor like like this is my life
you know when I when I finished this car
I'd be going outside to check them
before I go to bed when I wake up in the
morning that'd be the first thing I see
in the morning after my wife you know
the level of care these are very high in
maintenance animals
I hear you a lot just last week I was
mocking out four horses four mornings of
the week spoiling them rotten there's
nothing I love more than horses but I
think I represent a sort of a fair
decent proportion of the British public
and then I eat meat
um I ride horses and not everyone rides
horses of course but I you I can also
respect that the Grand National is to
speak spectacle that people enjoy going
to but I also care about animals like
Alex at the beginning of our
conversation We're a nation of animal
lovers a lot of us have lots of pets we
want to know that animals are being
taken uh care of um I just before we ran
out of time I want to talk about this
planned demonstration this weekend Alex
can you give us a sense of what is being
planned at Aintree yes so we're we're
going down to eight tree we're gonna
we're asking for people to come and join
us at night 9 30 from when in front of
the gates at Aintree uh we're going to
be there all day we're going to be
protesting we're going to try to disrupt
the race and we're doing that to bring
attention to the fact that we've got a
broken relationship with animals in the
natural world you know like that broken
relationship is at the center of many of
the problems we face you know like the
way that we treat animals is responsible
for the the wildlife problems we're
suffering from the industrial Farms that
are polluting our Rivers you know like
all of these things are wrapped up in
the fact that we should be a nation of
animal lovers that treat animals well so
we're going to go to the we're going to
go there we can bring you many more than
300 people we've got lots and lots of
supporters coming down we're asking many
more people to come and be there with us
and we're going to try to disrupt the
race because we believe it's wrong I
just I'm getting close
to move on but
by doing the Race outside
let's let's see what it is a reaction
and Kevin I want to just give you a
final word as well about how you feel
about that disruption to the race this
weekend
oh she look no no one would ever
discourage peaceful protests you know
it's right everyone has but to to you
know illegally disrupt the race
potentially putting horses and humans at
risk is is just silly and I'm sure it
won't happen
um look the thing is that ironically
like myself and Alex like are clearly on
very different sides of this debate
Rosanna but we'd actually have an awful
lot of common ground like I don't doubt
the sincerity of him or his supporters
and thinking they have the best
interests of uh thoroughbreds at heart
but look we know thoroughbreds this is a
breed that we have created we've curated
over 300 years they have very highly
specialized needs we know how to meet
them we know how to look after them no
one is resting on their Laurels we know
the world is changing but trust me I'm
on the ground day in day out the racing
authorities the people involved directly
with the horses are doing everything
they can to reduce risk to the lowest
possible level we can but such is life
we can never reduce risk to zero Kevin
Alex you've both
across your points very well this
evening thank you so much for insights
well next tonight Biden's back at it
again in Ireland another speech another
gaffe but with the US president
appearing to confirm he'll be running
again in 2024. I'll be asking is Joe
Biden too old for office that's next
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage stretching it you
can say whatever gender you are for your
sex your male or your female all right
JJ plus he become fabulous
he sucks out this five-point plan what
has it achieved so far nothing when we
say believe women take them at their
word I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read the book
[Music]
coming up on The Talk The sussexes are
said to be struggling with the Royal
Rift as Harry stays on the sidelines for
coronation proceedings President Biden
is at it again with another
uncomfortable Gap during an address in
Ireland and we've got the new rules of
dating to update you on so you need to
grab a pen all that and plenty more at
nine o'clock
foreign
before he comes back from holiday let's
have some fun shall we it's already been
fun joined in the studio now by our
panel for the evening it's two over some
news comedian and commentator sajila
Kashi talk TV presenter Richard Tice
joins us back here and talk to these
International editor Isabel Oak shot all
three of you lovely to have you and you
know with no favoritism at all but
Richard uh coming back in after we had
quite a heated conversation at the top
of the show there about uh brexit
obviously we have very different
positions but we wanted to show the
viewers uh this because when uh you and
I were talking about uh the cptpp which
was the Asian trade pack we're actually
talking to Danny Blanche flower who's an
economist we were speaking to him in the
U.S Richard was sitting next to me in
the studio under strict orders not to
comment to listen to Danny and this was
Danny's sorry this was Richard's
reaction as Danny was talking
Goods to cross Frontiers and not have to
bother with ridiculous trade deals with
some East Asian Southeast Asian country
that will raise GDP by 0.0001 in a
decade and that was considered to be an
overestimate as well we just had to show
you that because uh it was quite
extraordinary in the studio Richard I
couldn't resist it but I kept quiet but
I just had to explain in in sort of
Graphics that he was completely wrong oh
wow actually think you gave him a bit
too easier time I was listening says you
let him prattle on for absolutely
about the advantages of brexit I like
broadcasting set out their store but I
think you know we we we loaded up quite
hard against you both me and Barnesville
sharing quite a similar view on things
look we're not going to continue to talk
about brexit because we're just going to
be accused of being Ramona's let's talk
about President Biden rather who in
Ireland today uh was having a meeting
now there have been all these
allegations sajila thanks so much for
joining us this evening uh that he is
too biased in his Irish ancestry in his
love for Ireland yesterday when we were
talking about this I was thinking um
probably over egged he's a diplomat he
knows how to handle this but let's take
a listen
tie I have with a shamrock on it this
was given to me by one of these guys
right here it was a hell of a rugby
player and they beat down a little black
and tans I got him you can hear the
audience they're not quite sure if
they've realized what he said he said
black and tans he apparently according
to the White House meant All Blacks the
rugby team not the police force that
face the IRA back in the early 20th
century but it is a massive Gaff or is
it not sejula this is interesting
because was it a gaffe or did he know
what he was saying uh I suspect like the
little mischievous inside of me thinking
so maybe he did it on purpose like uh
because he firstly how has he left the
U.S you know how has that happened
because I go away for a couple of months
and I don't watch the news and suddenly
like Biden's well and and like really
very you know kind of like a energetic
he's out there in Ireland really
claiming his Irish route and I think
back in 2020 they said that uh the Irish
passport was more powerful than the US
and the UK so maybe he just wants an
Irish passport I don't know but I think
I think I don't I don't I just think all
these little gaps I'm not sure now I'm
not actually convinced that he does them
accidentally I think he's there's a
little Isabel yeah yeah I'm generous
there I mean That's a classic Gaff of
somebody who has been reading his brief
on the plane coming over he's been skim
reading it or someone's been verbaling
it to him he's remembered something
about the history and the black and tans
and he just basically drops it in by
myself it's completely it's a mistake a
slip up just Association that it's
deliberate that is physically it's a
great embroidian slip definition yes he
is 80. there's another thing though
which is that it transpires that his
limousine in Northern Ireland which
should have had the uh the Union Jack
Flag on it along with the US uh flag it
didn't it had the flag of the Republic
of that so I think that some of this
stuff is very deliberate I don't know
whether the black and tans is or whether
it's just the fact that he's an 80 year
old who is clearly struggling but uh
it's it's nevertheless it's it's pretty
serious and he frankly he should just do
better he's the leader of the Free World
looking back at some of the history of
Biden's comments about Ireland and
England specifically as well because
he's blamed his father for giving him an
English name uh and you know is does
that make him anti-british but there
have been so many comments to do over
the years of Biden's just basically
trying to renounce his English ancestry
but promote his Irish or maybe maybe
he's confused and he doesn't actually
know which island
i-s-l-a-n-d
you know what day it is I mean if he's
18 years old I think he's gonna get away
with it however actually America needs
to do better because you know he should
he's 80. and I don't want to be ages
because I think you can do things at any
age and we're all getting older so we
want to keep jobs and stuff but um I
just think so perhaps whoever's advising
him just needs to do better you know the
people around him I blame them not him
so much let's talk about upper age
limits for power then because there's
even been debate there was in the Sunday
Times this week saying you know should
people over the certain age stop having
driving licenses because there's a huge
proportional risk of older people and
behind the wheel and the risks that that
can have but in terms of holding the
office of the United States President
we've got Trump and Biden going up
against each other by more or less
reannouncing his runs is it okay
Elizabeth
um no I don't think there should be a
cut-off point it's all to do with what
you're how you're physically and
mentally able to cope and it's quite
evident over the course of his
presidency that Joe Biden is struggling
you know there have been numerous gaffes
his delivery and speeches which is after
all very important if you're the
president or any leading politician is
extraordinarily erratic you know he will
waffle on you lose if you're the
audience you lose the thread of it he's
obviously lost the threat of it I don't
think he's all there there's not
fortunately too much longer to go of
this presidency but the idea of him
re-running I think is extraordinary and
I would be astonished if the American
people voted for more of the same you
more or less accuse Richard of waffling
on at the start of the show does that
mean
there shouldn't be an upper age limit
but it is extraordinary that in the
United States you've got
um the sort of the leading Republican
Contender is 78 and Joe Biden the
president is saying he's going to run it
at the age of 80. how is it that America
in the nicest possible way can't come
come up with with something uh a bit
younger a bit more Dynamic that uh that
sort of Unites and inspires the nation
that would be like Obama was your lot
basically yeah that's it you've got a
good looking young
but I mean yeah
look you know we that people vote who
they vote for so you can't you know it's
it's democracy and if you vote for old
people then they're going to get in on
me I don't know maybe America do better
that was my question why isn't there any
uh younger more vibrant inspirational
leaders talking which Meghan Markle uh
would it be Pierce Morgan and said
without us talking about Meghan Markle
and Prince Harry or the sussexes rather
I should call them okay the latest in
the coronation we now know that Harry is
coming next month the coronation we know
that Megan is staying behind originally
we heard it was because it was Archie's
fourth birthday the kids but it's on the
same day the prince uh now we're hearing
her spiritual advisor saying well
actually it's probably bestie stairway
Isabel your reaction says it all well my
reaction is just I don't really want to
listen to a spiritual advisor I mean
that's ridiculous I think they've
actually made a graceful decision here
we don't know the extent to which they
were forced into it by the palace but I
think this is the absolutely the right
decision uh Prince Harry needs to come
in and be seen to be there I think
you'll get the hell out pretty quickly
she would have been a huge distraction
doubtless there would have been booing
it would have been very uncomfortable
for the rest of the royal family
um so I think it was the right decision
I don't know why you're making that
funny face oh because we're bushes we
don't boo people
[Laughter]
that is
the absurdity of the lady I mean it's
just ridiculous she tries to sort of
infer that she's she understands
Ordinary People and she she cares about
things and she's got a spiritual Guru no
I don't think she has a spiritual Guru I
think what it is that they got the story
well he did hear their podcast and
suddenly he's come out because it's
Deepak Chopra which is quite frankly I
thought he was dead I'm sorry but you
know I did and uh he's you know he's
obviously come out 79s another person
who's you know geriatric and trying to
get be relevant but um God I'm sounding
really ageless today but I really am not
and and I just think that it it was the
right decision I agree with you there
couldn't have been any other decision I
wouldn't want to be booed I know that
you know the UK hates her that's how I
would feel and plus you've got your
children it's birthday it's the right
decision for this situation she's she
could she does she's down there she does
she's down if she doesn't it's almost as
though what's more of interest is the
fact that Harry is is coming in and out
and he's not even going to go to the
Palace to the to the sort of the party
afterwards uh or apparently I'm bad at
the he's probably worried to be fished
highlights the depth of the collapse the
Calamity in the relationship how do they
recover from this I mean at his father's
own coronation is there a path to reform
for Harry
I mean I I can't see it you know you
listen to all the people who are experts
in this and who have spoken to all the
people close to them and it just doesn't
look recoverable I think the trusting is
crucial isn't it how can they have any
conversation you know absolutely trust
credibility means lots of the British
public that is it from us peers is back
on Monday in the seat but just a
reminder before we go that our Wall
Street Journal colleague Evan
gershkovich remains unjustly detained in
Russia and we of course called his
immediate release whatever he up to
tonight make sure it's uncensored want
to thank Richard Isabel sergila in the
studio with me it's been great talking
to all of you do stay with us good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it